[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie it's Comic Con
week and Barry is back on the flash we
got to break this down it's also like
the week that I can walk around with
this on and not get arrested because
it's Comic Con week I will be talking
about the schedule at the end of this
but there will be extra flash ring
giveaway is all you have to do to enter
those be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so before we get
into Comic Con we have to talk about
Barry Allen coming back notice I didn't
say the flash coming back because we saw
Barry on set Frank us that posted this
picture of himself clean-shaven looking
like the Barry that you remember he
posted the time-lapse of them shaving
his Grizzly Adams vacation beard off the
important thing is that he posted this
while they were filming episode two
actually they've been filming it for a
couple of days after we've seen Wally in
the red suit several times so now we
have an idea for the timeline of Barry's
return so what it sounds like happens is
through the course of episode 1 Wally's
been Kid Flash for a while trying to
protect the city he steps up his game in
order to strike some more fear into the
hearts of the villains and the robot
Samurai the samurais that he's fighting
at all these behind-the-scenes pictures
we see puts Barry's costume on saves the
day but through the course of his
actions starts to get hints about what's
going on with Barry and why it's so
important that he comes back so they
tease Prison Break obviously all the
stuff with them pulling Barry out of the
Speed Force in him physically coming
back is going to be green-screen so
we're not going to get any sneak peek at
that until we see the actual trailer on
Saturday but obviously he's going to
come back he's going to be the flash
it'll be a great season we already know
a little bit about the villain
we know the mechanic is going to be the
helper to the thinker just like the
tinkerer was the helper to the vulture
and spider-man homecoming there was a
new actress that they just cast in the
mystery role people are wondering if
that might be who the mechanic is but
I'll talk about that in a second the
bigger thing is that is Grant Gustin was
posting these behind the scenes pictures
of like hey everybody Barry's back
Jessica Camacho was also in her trailer
on set with this comic book t-shirt on
blast off comics is just a comic book
store in Burbank California but it means
that gypsy is on set she wasn't wearing
her traditional costume but the actress
is
now a recurring guest star in season
four meaning that as much as you saw
gypsy in the back half of season three
that's about how much you'll see or the
first half of the season the second half
of the season but when they say
recurring guest star it just means that
they'll show up every once in a while on
a pretty regular basis but not every
single episode
meaning the Sisko is probably going to
get some pretty sweet action I'm sure
he's pretty pumped about this because
we're going to be seeing so much of her
they might delve into the backstory of
her father on earth 19 who is a really
big villain from the comics called
breacher we might see the emergence of
him as another big bad in addition to
the thinker he's just a potential bill
and they could always do in a future
season but we haven't done a whole lot
with verse 19 besides HR may he rest in
peace in gypsy like we haven't spent a
whole lot of time there so this would be
the season to do that if you're going to
have a whole lot of gypsy and it means
you know even bigger thing I kind of
buried the lead on this the T
accelerated man comes back to
everybody's always been asking about him
who's underneath the mask is that hunter
zolomon of earth 19 no that's not him
it's not Eddie it's a different actor
that they cast specifically for that
role but I'm just expecting them to
bring him back the next time we do some
earth 19 specific story but unless he's
going to be part of the bigger plot
would probably only see him a couple
times but like the black flash came on
briefly for a little while then he
recurred on the other shows a couple big
time so you wanted more accelerated man
you're going to get more accelerated man
they always do that
introduce a character everybody loves
them they always bring him back in a
bigger way so last big thing before we
talked about Comic Con schedule there's
an actress named Eliza Villani that was
just cast in a mystery role people are
wondering who she is is she going to be
the mechanic and be like the miner bad -
the big bad that is the thinker I don't
think that's the case just scanning her
IMDB she's mostly only had minor roles
on other CW shows and I think if they're
going to cast somebody against their big
bat like this really big actor who's
going to be in his 40s or 50s they would
probably look for somebody who has had a
little more experience to pair with that
person so it seems more likely that
she's not playing a really huge
character and should just be on for one
episode we can push deeper into that as
they make more casting announcements but
here's the big thing Comic Con because
there's so many things that are dropping
between
Wednesday in Sunday and I have like all
the other regular videos that I would
normally do like Game of Thrones on
Sunday what's going to happen is I'm
going to make a special playlist at the
top of my channel so when you go to the
main page you'll see it like right there
at the top and you can just go back and
check in case you missed videos as I
post them there won't be more than three
videos per day with the exception of
Saturday so here's what's happening
Wednesday is still pretty chill the
first episode of Krypton is airing I
might post a review video for that
they're doing a panel they took
everybody's trailer videos down so I
might just repost that but Thursday is
really when stuff starts happening
they're doing the Fox panel that's
Deadpool - New Mutants in maybe a little
bit of Dark Phoenix so whatever footage
drops I'll do a video for it then Friday
is really huge - there's the Young
Justice season 3 panel Game of Thrones
Rick and Morty
Walking Dead in the marvel defenders
panel with the Punisher so they're doing
defenders and Punisher whatever trailers
drop I'll do videos for but like I said
I'll probably only be able to do three
so I'll just post updates on my Twitter
and Facebook about which videos are
going to post win and what my status
report is as we go along and then the
main show is Saturday that's when all
the really big stuff drops the first big
thing is Justice League they're
definitely dropping a Justice League
trailer yeah of course I'll do a video
for it they're going to have an Aquaman
panel there's all of the CW DC TV shows
each one of those shows is dropping
their trailer and then after that
there's all the Marvel movies and there
will definitely be at least a Thor
Ragnarok trailer and a new Black Panther
trailer everybody's asking if they're
going to drop an Infinity Ward teaser
it's possible but I'm not expecting it
and maybe an arrow trailer Sunday
morning before Game of Thrones get
started but sunday will be relatively
normal and then anything that I missed
out on that you guys really want me to
do videos for I'll do Monday through
next week so I'll just catch all the
stuff that I skip over on Monday so no
worries there but any special video
requests you guys have just leave them
in the comments below it is things get
started on Wednesday night I'll just
start updating everybody on when
everything is posting on Twitter and
Facebook so we should all be good but
I'll announce the winner of the next
flash ring giveaway when I post
my next DC video so while you wait for
that click here for brand new flash
season 4 and you can click here for the
trailer for next week's game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight